there is nothing in the Constitution
that says the president who is the
executive right he's not supposed to
write laws he's just supposed to sign
them right that's how this thing works
or it's supposed to work there's
obviously nothing in the Constitution
about that we tried to find something
pretty non-partisan to recap what's
going on here I chose NBC News here's
Lester Holt who I don't think is
particularly good he's done some
horrible hit pieces on Jordan Peterson
in the past but here's basic information
from NBC my God they can do it every now
and again good evening and welcome
everyone in a pair of cases that will
impact tens of millions of student loan
borrowers the Supreme Court heard
arguments today on whether the Biden
administration had the authority to
forgive some of those loans the
president's loan debt relief plan calls
for erasing up to twenty thousand
dollars in student loans for certain
borrowers at an estimated cost of 400
billion dollars but it was put on hold
last Fall by an appeals court today the
plan appeared to face new headwind wins
before The Supreme Court as conservative
justices questioned whether the
president was acting within the law the
White House defending the plan tonight
as a helping hand for those getting back
on their feet after the pandemic but
critics say the program is patently
unfair for those who paid their debt or
who never took out a loan in the first
place it's so interesting even the way
they frame that and that was the best
NBC could do but it's a it's a helping
hand by the Democrats but that doesn't
mean it's constitutional the
conservative justices have concerns
about the law well their Supreme Court
justices they have law clerks they're
experts in law and it's a pretty high
court up there says Supreme right The
Supremes this is pretty good
the Democrats with their Helping Hands
the Democrats are just trying to help
people but those conservative judges
have concerns about it's just so boring
and ridiculous look it's simply not in
the Constitution I cannot imagine how
the judges would actually go for this
thing the president even if the
president means well I mean that's what
Lester all say the President's trying to
be nice the president doesn't want
people to have that so come on come on
foreign
[Music]